we turn to the phone lines right now and
fine let me put the Michigan helmet
right there in front of me the head
coach University of Michigan football
and my first quarterback is being a
Michigan Wolverine on campus when I was
a freshman there in Ann Arbor back in
1986 he is Jim Harbaugh how are you
coach rich good to be with you as well
how's your folks how is everybody
everybody healthy happy yeah yeah well
the both my mom and dad they're 80 but
you know they they're doing great and
happy for that but a lot of gratitude of
course of course
and are they you are you call quarantine
together as one family are you on
because I know you you live right nearby
next door right nor to each other so so
yeah we do we do see him though we were
literally walking you know walk across
walks there having a walk ups oh gosh
that's amazing yeah you know you know of
court no no I understand obviously you
know but so many people like I FaceTime
my mom a lot it would be great to just
you know hey here's the grandkids right
there you could just wave hello just
that would be great I'm glad you have
that opportunity to do something like
that okay so where do things stand right
now for for you and the football season
right now coach do you do we do we think
we've got something cooking here what's
on your mind on that front yeah I do I
do believe that there's a lot of people
with a lot of opinions right now that's
for sure um you know I think you see the
NFL with the Commissioner one person
probably making that decision you know
getting a lot of get a lot of advice and
sure but you know college football
there's this there's more involved
multiple commissioners school presidents
boards of Regents but yeah I know I know
players and players on our team I want
to play and hoping for better news as
the weeks goes go on and but
and revved up you know Motors revved up
with wanting somewhere to go no I know
and obviously you know our school
president saying in his mind that you
know if there's no kids on campus
there'll be no football and that there's
a level of doubt and again you're you're
the football coach you know as you point
out there's others who are who are
making certain decisions have you have
you reached out to other coaches within
the conference to hear what what's going
on on other campuses or what are you
what are you where's your stance on that
front oh yeah we talk we do a weekly
call with all the Big Ten head coaches
and athletic directors and Kevin Warren
our Commissioner and Mark Ratner lotsa
lots of folks and we're doctors on that
call so you get you get updates so you
know you know what the NCAA is is saying
that voluntary workouts can begin June
1st
looks like mandatory will be July 1st
June 1st for voluntary so that's that's
kind of what we're we're at so Monday is
June 1st and if the states are open and
they're and they're not sheltering in
place still then then and the football
players athletes can come back to campus
on a voluntary basis and cyndi workouts
right have you become more of a public
health expert than you ever thought
you'd be coach yeah I like everybody
right I mean yeah right well I read a
lot I do that I've been reading a lot
and what even read watch watch a lot of
you know News cetera well you've watched
all the judge Judy's there is I know
that so what are you what are you what
are you reading what are you doing well
I mean today I'd say or whatever I'm
really very very upset about the George
Floyd death and that's kind of got me
preoccupied today I'm not just very
horrendous very very I'm very just
watching right now and
I'm looking looking forward to there'd
be an investigation and and waiting for
that charges that's completely a
outrageous yeah I know you I'm sure you
you're you're obviously on on a campus a
college campus where that I'm sure is a
major discussion you're also a former
coach of Colin Kaepernick and you see
all the memes out there if this is why
he knelt when was the last time you
spoke to Colin coach is if anyone ago we
texted every now and then I'll get a
text from Colin or I'll text him but I
think that without that there were there
was a graphic I saw that too you know
this is why he this is why he now that's
was it the LeBron James who who tweeted
that I think so yeah I might have
exactly if you didn't if you didn't know
now if you didn't know then you know now
that spoke volumes I thought Jim
Harbaugh Michigan football head coach
here on the on the Rich Eisen show where
are you again I guess I'm protocols and
health and safety you know with with
have you reached out to obviously you've
got a health care a great health care
school on the on the campus and I'm sure
is there if I spoke tin to other head
coaches and saying that they this needs
to be in the hands of parents before
they return to campus I'm wondering
where you are on that front before we
kind of turn to the concept of playing
football yeah definitely there's a lot
of things they're a great health system
at Michigan our presidents a commune
ologist
doctor and so there's a lot of smart
people I got confidence you know that
they're gonna give us the right
direction and as you said I think it's a
really important piece and we we've done
it is is reached out to our parents and
and just hey this is our team these are
your sons
what do you think is what do you think
is is right how do you want to do this
and
got a lot of got a lot of great feedback
a lot um Stan you got a lot of smart
parents and and by the way their parents
yes so uh that was tremendous feedback
and they even shared some of the
protocols that they have but whether
some of the companies that worked at
Ford Motor Company and others some are
doctors you know some had had terrific
suggestions and and a survey of and and
and also comments and tremendous things
tremendous things come came back we're
so what that's that's actually helping
us and in a big way and we're gonna go
forward and we're going to visit as a
team again and I'm Saturday if a lot of
parents in the and the athletes and and
tell them where we're at and what we're
what we're looking for
what what what has to happen things have
to happen on with the local local
governances the state governance is the
University so you know yeah and they're
and they're great and they're really
understanding you don't beat the coach
up too much because you know we don't
know that much and sometimes it changes
course from week to week let alone
sometimes day to day so but yeah
everybody's everybody's be respectful
everybody's uh you know doing what
they're you know what they're respectful
of of what the doctors are saying
respectful of the of the virus and and
ultimately we want the health and safety
of the you know the guys the coaches the
staff and and you know with everybody
you know the community to be the
priority I think and and that's being
done so that's just really you know what
there is to say about that and I I can
applaud people because people are doing
the right thing they have been doing the
right thing and I think you know at the
time there's you know two weeks and then
it's really turned any more like two
months but the curve splat and that was
that's what everybody was
we set out to do and you know let's keep
keep going let's keep just keep
attacking this with enthusiasm unknown
to mankind unknown to mankind absolutely
and the engines are revved the engine
revs rich and and we want somewhere to
go to you know I'm sure I'm sure you
know and and obviously Michigan Stadium
would be a great place to start and I
know you already said to you know if
there's no fancy snow fans just want to
get out there in the meantime that's the
boys they I mean that's what the guys
are saying right there they're initially
shocked at the well there's a
possibility there might not be fans and
yeah I mean that's uh that's a that's a
that's a real possibility because you
could test you could test the
participants the players the coaches the
officials the chain gang the the
trainer's etc but maybe probably tough
to test a hundred thousand people coming
into a store yes and they understand
that and I go here's a question would
you rather would you rather not would
you rather play in front of no fans or
not play and Intuit to a guy you know
they'd rather play so that's that's some
of the feedback Jim Harbaugh here on the
Rich Eisen show who's the quarterback
gonna be how do you evaluate that right
now what is the current evaluation at
that very crucial position coach you
know that's that's to be seen we got
some we got some some guys we really
love and you know they've been chomping
at the bit Meza guys those guys that are
excited to get back to working out with
the team and back to practicing but our
quarterbacks in particular they're
they're chomping at the bit which is
which is better and but it is an open
competition is what you're saying for
that business yeah how do you how do you
conduct that when you might not be able
to get them on the field get your you
know right now you're just you know
zooming or whatever you're doing I
I know that your first your first year
in the NFL was if I'm not mistaken you
walk straight into a labor dispute I'm
wondering if anything like that is is
anything that you're you're drawing upon
to make a an evaluation from afar like
this yeah yeah drawn a little bit of
that experience in 2011 when there was
the lockout and so there are some
similarities so the things I've drawn
from it or you know you got it you got
to really consider everything day by day
week by week plan for the different
different scenarios and there's going to
be a lot of them and some are going to
learn more as it as it goes on and you
don't know when exactly when you're
going to start but but also try to be as
creative and proactive so you can be as
productive as possible and and
specifically with the quarterbacks I
mean we've we've been having some
meetings we've been installing football
and you know told our guys a learning
system you know the best you can you
know you know be an expert at it
when we do get back together and also
getting the best best shape of your life
and and and throw the football get out
and throw it every day and and each guy
you know that through the quarterbacks
in my mind here you know each one has
has done that and taken advantage of
that and gotten guys to throw to and
kind of fill in McCaffrey's been been
throwing with his brothers Christian and
Luke and in Denver and Joe milton's been
in Orlando and then he came back to Ann
Arbor and you got a bag of balls and
finding guys to throw with and Kate
McNamara's got that his brother is going
to be a incoming freshman wide receiver
and then they're there call him chomping
at the bit and what can they do and
getting coached Ben McDaniel has been
coaching them everyday you know that
they're having the uninstallation
and going over foot working
kind of stuff so I know those guys are
chomping at the bit so only all are and
we hope yeah hopefully better news here
in the next couple weeks as it relates
to Michigan that that you know our
governor will open up a little bit more
so we can get back together and guys can
can do voluntary work out so before I
let you go
couldn't help but notice this video made
the rounds after Jayden hood from my
buddy Michael Irvin's alma mater st.
Thomas Aquinas in Fort Lauderdale he
committed to the University of Michigan
and you celebrated with a cartwheel
that's you right that is definitely you
I could see that you gave a go blue one
was what was the last how often do you
cartwheel Jim how often is this
happening okay so I can't comment on any
recruiting and and so can we say okay
that's oh okay let me rephrase let me
rephrase video of you on online occurred
cartwheeling for something I don't know
what it was for but you cartwheeled and
my question is is when was the last time
how often is this did you did you did
you alright first of all I need to make
sure that was you did a cartwheel for
whatever yeah and or did we emerge from
this victorious do we emerge from this
with no with nothing lingering no
lingering injuries no injuries a little
disappointed that I didn't get my my
legs up more to you know 90 degree angle
okay is that core work is that could be
we can work on that that we could work
on that or is it or is that upper body I
mean what what do what are you or just
again yeah its core shoulders I think I
mean could be khakis it could be I mean
tastic gymnastics move that uh okay was
the analog way I didn't get myself very
high I point great for that okay but I
mean again you're in
khakis it looks like you do have some
some you know you could blame it on the
fabric but again it's still very
impressive I couldn't do any of that
that's very impressive and you got a
Ravens gear on you sure that's not John
we sure know there's me in a Ravens
t-shirt okay okay very good
hey you got it all on there hey Jim Bob
I you rich I mean the 40-yard dash we
all pale in comparison I appreciate you
saying that well my whole family sends
their best to you and my best to your
entire family Jim let's uh let's stay in
touch catch up soon thanks to the call
of course rich stay safe you and your
family and go blow buddy right back at
you that said Jim Harbaugh go blue hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here